there's a person named mig west who uh
is a skeptic and tries to take a
skeptical view on every single piece of
evidence on these ufo sightings uh what
do you think about his analysis he tries
to
analyze in a way that debunks some of
these videos
and assign probabilities to their
explanations sort of leaning towards
things that uh
give a very low probability to
um alien extraterrestrial type of
explanations for these ufos what do you
think about
his approach to these uh analysis well
two parts to his approach one i commend
him for all the good work and effort he
put into it
i've seen him build some models and
things of that nature
and so i think that's something that's
absolutely needed in this environment no
one's asking anyone to believe anyone
here right
trust but verify
should certainly be the mantra
but where i have you know a disagreement
with his approach is that he's
approaching from you know from a skeptic
or from a debunker standpoint and you
know from my perspective not not
speaking for everyone but
when i hear that that tells me that
you're driving towards a particular
conclusion
which has been a very safe
process for the past x years right it's
been a it's been like a very safe
business to be in to tell people that
they haven't seen aliens but uh times
have changed a little bit and
the tactics i've seen to try to retain
that
view on reality
um
has included things such as completely
dismissing what the air crew are saying
and i think that is a fallacy to think
that we have to take the human outside
of that analysis
you